hello time for the press preview then a
first look at what is on the front pages
it's time to check out what is making
headlines tonight with the columnist
carol malone and the editor of the
courier in dundee david clegg they're
going to be with us from now until just
before midnight very good evening to
both of you chat in a moment first of
all let's check out those front pages
for you starting with the metro it calls
the seizure of a british trawler by
french maritime officials a kick in the
scallops as heated negotiations continue
between the two nations over post-brexit
fishing rights
and the star has an almost identical
headline though the telegraph plays it
straight declaring johnson summons
french ambassador over fish rao
here's the i carries analysis for an
independent think tank which suggests
low and middle-income households will be
left worse off by yesterday's budget
it also means an increase in mortgages
as well as tax bills that's according to
the times
tensions ahead of the cop 26 climate
summit are the main concern for the ft's
international edition the world's two
biggest polluters china and india have
of course refused to commit to abiding
by global emissions standards
davis paper the courier speaks to saint
andrews university student kyono fazil
whose drink was spiked at a recent party
which as we know has been a growing
problem hasn't it of late
the express hears that e-cigarettes
could soon be made available on the nhs
to help people quit
tomorrow's mail says that would make the
uk the first country in the world to
offer e-cigarettes on prescription
same story actually uh on the front of
the guardian
and the sun says the girlfriend of
footballer chris cristiano ronaldo is
pregnant with twins
nice news to end on and that we're
joined tonight by carol malone and david
clegg good to see you lots in the papers
uh lots of different front pages
actually but many of them are going with
this row
over uh fishing
and the row that is escalating uh carol
yeah yes this is weird because a couple
of weeks ago it looked like it was all
going quite well you know the sausage
war looked like it was ending after um
you said that they would they would wave
checks on 80 of goods that were coming
over and so chilled meats and we were
going to be allowed to you know put
things from here to northern ireland but
it's all kind of blown up again with the
seizure of this trawler there i think
it's the cornelius or cornelius that i
have said um yeah i mean it's kind of
outrageous really you know macron you
know
for weeks now he's been threatening
this country he's been saying he's going
to block the channel tomorrow he's going
to he's going to block our ports he's
going to he basically wants to stop us
trading because he can't accept the fact
that that you know that brexit has
happened and now they've upped the
temperature by by
taking this boat which they say
doesn't have a license but the owner of
the boat says absolutely does have a
license and i don't quite see what
macron's problem is here it's all about
the fishing licenses france are saying
that they they want more fishing
licenses granted but actually law frost
has actually said that britain has
granted 98
of all the license applications from the
eu and they are looking favorably on the
rest of them so i don't quite know what
macron wants i suspect it's to do with
the fact that b has an election coming
up in the next few months and this is
him just posturing and looking looking
like the big i am because a lot of the
french fishermen are on le pen's in le
pen's camp so he wants to to make them
feel that he's looking after them uh
david it'd be good to get your view on
this um uh from your part of of the
world your sister paper uh the preston
journal running it on its front page
scott's firm's boat caught in the eye uh
of the fishing storm i mean what's the
view on the ground where you are
yeah i think people are very concerned
obviously this was a big issue in the
brexit debate a lot of fishermen in
scotland voted for brexit because they
were concerned about fishing quotas and
that the long rehearsed problems with
the eu and how that all worked we've
there's been a long process to this
point and i think one of the things i've
sensed a little bit is opponents of
brexit are perhaps coming at this at the
wrong way because i think the french
have been acting very unreasonably here
as carol said i think it's 98 of these
french fishing boats would have which
had to show some history or record of
having fished in uk waters previously
have been able to do so and the french
response to to the problems that the two
percent are having has been you know
very aggressive in fact and and there's
problems with this in jersey as well and
they've been threatening to shut off
electricity to jersey which seems like a
quite incredible threat for the for the
french government to be making so
fishermen are very concerned about it in
scotland the president journal's been
covering this issue widely as you say
and this is about people's livelihoods
it's about their jobs this shouldn't be
about some kind of political retaliation
there shouldn't be a hangover of uh ill
feeling or resentment about brexit there
is a an agreed process for how these
types of issues should be dealt with so
i think the scottish fisherman
federation which has been
uh talking about this issue on this
channel earlier on today i saw they're
very concerned about this as well they
would really hope that calm heads
prevail and that the french take a
slightly
less
intense attitude towards trying to
resolve these technical difficulties
yeah interesting you say comheads should
prevail some of the language is
interesting front of the metro kick in
the scallops it's similar on the front
of the daily star and i note in the
metro carol that andrew bridgen
backbench tory mp of course has said
history shows our great nation's
interests are best served by standing up
to threats of little napoleon's clinging
onto power i mean that sort of language
isn't helpful is it
well you see it's not helpful but it's
kind of you know with macron it's kind
of true the guy is fostering you know as
david just said his language has been
has been appalling over the past few
weeks as has his what she's called the
french seas minister anik giardon she
has she was the one who threatened
jersey in the first place threatened to
cut off the energy altogether and and
today it's risen it's head it's risen
his head again and then i've threatened
to put higher tariffs on the energy the
stress is actually making this into
something and even unless we stand up to
them they're going to carry on doing it
and it looks like we are standing up
because lord frost has now called
together the xo cabinet committee to
talk about starting the article 16
process he has said to them it's always
been on the table and he doesn't want to
do it but you know unless we get some
kind of agreement he doesn't see another
option and now he's called together this
this meeting they're going to have
meetings in the next few days he's
summoned the french ambassador so it's
you know we have to act against the
french threats the language that the
region used maybe isn't the right
language but we can't let the french
threaten us the way they are doing yeah
david there's really been a situation
that andrew bridgen hasn't made worse i
think and just because the the french if
we think the french are behaving
erratically or the way they're
approaching it has not been appropriate
i think that
reciprocating that type of attitude is
not it's not going to be beneficial here
i think i think what the fishermen in
scotland and this part of the world want
is for both governments of both
countries to come together sort this
problem out it's a it's a small issue
affecting a small number of boats uh
it's largely about paperwork and
technical processes so let's get effects
so people can get back to their
livelihoods because fishing is a very
dangerous occupation
it's dangerous enough without having
talks of talk of blockades and boats
being boarded in the middle of the night
and all this nonsense i think it really
needs to get resolved pretty quickly
these talks can't go on forever i think
i think lord frost has been incredibly
patient he's had to put up with a lot of
abuse from the french but the talks
can't go on forever they can't be
indefinite so something has to give
something's got to be done okay um let's
leave that there for the moment and move
on to another story it's on page four of
the metro uh this is all about angela
rayner um apologizing unreservedly uh
for those comments uh where she uh uh
called the uh conservatives tory scum
carol do you want to lead us off on this
one i mean she did she she absolutely
refused to apologize at the time didn't
she
do you know what this woman is actually
incredible this is way too little too
late she she's been asked to apologize
for weeks and weeks now i think the toy
conference was their labor conference
was about a month ago when she said all
this and let's get it right she called
tory's scum homophobes misogynists and
racists and she was asked time and again
to apologize and she didn't but what has
really angered me
today is where she says and she there's
a print of her apologies tonight she
said i sent my heartfelt condolences to
the family of sir david amos he was a
fine parliamentarian a proud advocate
for his constituents how dare she
piggyback on sir david amos's murder
this is the woman who just four weeks
ago said all tories were scum and
misogynist and here she is praising a
man who was murdered and i actually this
is just i suspect she's been told she
has to apologize well she says she says
in her i mean yeah it's a long statement
isn't it she said that she's had a
period of time out she says she's been
grieving personally
herself david did you agree with carol
no i don't i think i would have more
sympathy for angela rainer really it's
clear her comments were unacceptable i
think obviously with the events of of
recent weeks she's had time to reflect
on that i reflect on the example that
politicians should set with their
rhetoric in some way there's some
similarities to what we were discussing
about the
fishing situation carl's definitely
right that she'd been unrepentant at the
time that she had in fact doubled down
on it at the labour party conference
afterwards i think but she's clearly had
an unsettling time uh with her her own
troubles which have been in court about
uh offensive emails or threatening
emails that have been sent to her she's
she's seen the horrible murder of a mp
colleague
and the devastation that that has caused
and i think that it is a lengthy
statement i thought it was quite a
thoughtful statement and i think that
if someone makes an apology like that if
they express themselves at that length
say their previous conduct is not being
acceptable and they wouldn't conduct
themselves in that way in the future uh
my instinct would be to draw a line
under it carol you're itching to come
back we're out of time 10 seconds
okay i think this was politically
expedient she saw the fuss on twitter
last week about using this kind of
language and she's she's been she's
either decided or been totally attracted
for her own political future okay all
right we'll leave that one there thank
you both for the moment coming up why
one analysis of the budget says low and
middle income households will be worse
off that's after the break
[Music]
welcome back part two the press preview
david and carol uh still with us and
we'll take a look at the front of the
eye david uh all the analysis uh the day
after the budget uh return of the
squeeze middle this is the institute for
fiscal studies saying low and middle
income households are the ones that are
are going to face real pain
yes it's uh it's interesting because the
the story in some newspapers yesterday
i'm sorry this morning i should say
about about the budget where this was a
a budget of handouts i saw her she
seemed like the chancellor compared to
gordon brown in in some commentary and i
i think the thing that they've got very
much wrong there is that while this is
this has certainly been a spending spree
the way that the spending is being
targeted uh under this government is
very different than it was targeted
under the new labour government when
gordon brown was chancellor because it
redistributed wealth from the rich to to
the poor whereas that is not happening
in this is the ifs show today uh and
quite quite stark analysis really that
the there's going to be a real decline
in living standards uh for uh middle
income earners uh the the
tax rises which i think uh i think i'm
right in saying it's the the tax rises
since 1993 we're going to be the highest
rate of tax but they're not being
targeted at the well off uh the
distribution of it is actually going to
benefit the better off and and and cause
real problems and in fact real pain is
the phrase that the ifs used today uh
for for for people with uh less wealth
yeah high inflation rising taxes poor
growth all on the way
carroll but interestingly a sky news
poll said that 39 percent of people we
spoke to approved of the budget
yesterday thought it was a good budget
21
disapproved um so it would appear that
actually maybe
many people
think that things will be better for
them
you know whatever soon i did yesterday
there'd be lots of people saying it's
it's not the right thing to do i just
read today he's been accused of of of
just promoting this of showing off and
this is brand rishi what nonsense you
know the guy has guided us through covet
he kept he kept
thousands millions of people in work
with the furlough schemes you know he
was giving them 80 percent of their subs
this budget was is yes it's tax and
spent it's been a tsunami of spending
150 million quid on schools public
transport housing working families you
know david says it's been hit it's it's
there's nothing to the point yes there
is the minimum wage has been increased
by
6.6 and we know that universal credit is
is is going to go it's not going to go
up with the tapering scheme it's going
to mean that that the people who are
working get a lot more money every week
so
there is something in it for the poor
it's not fair to say yes low incomes are
going to feel real pain because we're
getting we're in the cost of living
crisis and we can't get away from that
and then the public sector rises you
know they say it won't be above
inflation but it will be an inflation
proofing rise which will mean that that
yes the risers they get will be enough
but the pub but the private sector have
got no rises at all to help them with
what's coming well
let's just before we go let's have a
quick look at the um the take uh of the
business section of the daily telegraph
david um it's saying uh the ifs also
reporting that chancellor is using kovid
as a as an excuse for as carol says that
spending tsunami
yes indeed and
i think obviously covert has a lot of
challenges and in fairness to the
chancellor a lot of this money is going
to be directed to the health service
which has not only the covert challenges
but also the backlog that we're all
aware of that has built up while while
the health service has been dealing with
chronovirus for the last 18 months so in
some way that is justified